doesn't go anywhere
see those two holes there I pushed the
hoenn for a meter and a half and it's
mad all the way okay I was gonna say
with only no shot for three years and
that's why still hang out we're trying
to connect the junior cave system which
is just up in this area off the edge and
the bottom end of Lucky Strike over here
it's a phenomenal feeling that you can't
really get anywhere else went on the
surface of the earth
everything's been met satellites have
gone over you can go on Google Earth and
discover it before you go there but
underground you don't know what's going
to be there
they take hundreds of thousands of years
to grow and develop and you can destroy
these things in an instant treat caves
with a respect these straws here
basically you just touch them and they
fall off the ceiling
totally hollow inside and there's water
running down the inside of them not on
the outside so funnily enough that's why
local schools there's been a lot of
people working on the overall project
for many decades we found a passage jr.
and we started digging in there the next
step is we need to pinpoint the exact
location of where they are and therefore
we know how far we have to do because it
could be ten meters but it also could be
50 meters lucky strike and junior are
two totally different caves lucky has
heaps of formations sporty stream way
touches roads lots of variety Junior
it's like kneeling in a bath of porridge
or the rainstorm coming down on your
head the reality is once you accept the
fact that you're gonna get dirty and
muddy it actually becomes a lot of fun
because it just opens the scope out to
play and the mud like you always wanted
to you know
[Music]
that's good to see the Sunday had a good
thing yeah enjoy that one no let's go
again yeah 1315 to go it might be a
would of course that you have to crawl
down on your belly
could be a chamber that's 100 meters
across and 100 meters high so yeah it's
the unknown which makes it exciting
that's beautiful that's the unknown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]